it's a huge test for Jake because the
volume of Nate the chin of Nate it you
know and after I was one of the first
guys after he fought Anderson like now I
can at first before he finally
understand I was like I don't like the
the Nate Diaz fight for Jake's terrible
idea he fought Anderson looked good
showed some boxing IQ you know was in
there he he got hurt he came back he
dropped the Henderson Silva I was like
oh [__] and he might be Nate's gonna be
some trouble you can't watch that if I
think that Nate's not in trouble they
see the time he Fury fight like okay is
this a good fight
right through the city like British
mission to get it on
if you ain't thick please don't get
involved
now Brandon
what is poppin family
gets a fam I say family it is Monday
April 17th how is everybody you good
there's a reason if you're watching this
right now on YouTube if you're listening
you can't tell but I have two pairs of
nuts hanging off my eyes your boy's
exhausted my uh oldest son who's seven
Big T Dog uh he recently has asthma and
then he I don't know if anyone does
anyone have asthma in there no he had to
asthma attack at one in the morning
which is pretty scary when your Critter
turns blue so your boy was up till about
four in the morning had to rush to the
emergency room
they gave him some you know they do all
these tests and calm them down and get
his lungs back to normal but no soccer
today no soccer today so that's how it
goes man life of a dad hanging out at
Urgent Care till four in the morning
hell yeah dude right on asthma not fun
uh fresh off the plane from Atlanta
Georgia shout out to Atlanta uh survived
the Linux Mall survived the Linux mall
and they also have one of my favorite
um steakhouses they're a little alleys
fantastic chin came there chin came with
us we went to uh the Georgia Aquarium
went to the Georgia Aquarium
um we got hooked up too we had the like
the behind the scenes tour which is dope
yeah it was fun right my boy Taylor uh
Sachem who in sichum is like the uh
cgum is based like the Coca-Cola for
fish products like they uh Supply
everyone they're super great products
especially if you have uh home aquariums
I took this picture because I'm a nerd
about this stuff I'm like doing the fish
tanks my fish are thriving uh they
arowana is getting so big your boy's
gonna have to upgrade its tank stresses
me out I think about it every day all
the time because it's so big you have to
get a giant tank that's a straight manta
ray there uh they had a tank that was
I think what do they say 1.2 million
gallons it was something insane yeah and
then uh I like because we had like the
behind the scenes tour because of our
boy Taylor but I like to see the the
setup the filter systems they use all
these pipes and plums you know
um the Plumbing's pretty dope and just
how they get all the filter and all that
stuff and then the lights for the reef
so I started recently getting the salt
water tanks haven't pulled trigger yet
looking at a Red Sea Aquarium so we'll
see it's a big commitment gotta be
honest fellas but the lighting to keep
the you know in nature like in the ocean
those corals need to thrive in a certain
kind of lighting so you have to purchase
those lights at your home well just each
light is around a thousand dollars right
six hundred thousand dollars look at
their lighting just on one freaking
aquarium and they were gigantic too huge
yeah I asked the guy the tour guide I'm
like hey how much these Linings like I
have no idea do you know anything about
lights I'm like I know just for a home
aquarium one stupid little bulbs about a
grand he's like think what that is I'm
like oh dude I don't know 500 000 bucks
and just in lighting just to get that
tank popping and that's their small tank
gotta be honest felt bad for the for the
what was it the the the white uh kind of
whale things oh belugas the Beluga yeah
that was that was he's just big enough
for them to turn around I was like this
suck yeah they're so cute too that's
bumming me out man yeah yeah it's tough
but shout out to Atlanta thanks for
coming out y'all we got a clip coming up
today about letting Bud Light should be
a fun one uh I had some great UFC fights
over the weekend y'all must have forgot
about Max Holloway son y'all must have
freaking forgot this is one of those
things that the UFC does you know with
Arnold Allen being undefeated in the UFC
not undefeated overall I think he's a
lot he lost once before this back in the
day but undefeating the UFC so kid's
definitely a prospect he's my Dark Horse
still become world champion but some you
know the toss a young lion a young young
London lion Arnold Allen uh to just a a
veteran who's been around forever former
world champion and usually usually it
goes like it would Jon Jones you know
versus a guy like uh
God John fought all the old heads you
know like a rampage or if you look at
John Chael Leona Machida Vitor Bell for
um all those guys the janitor you know
that was his first kind of test
um for me it was Gabriel Gonzaga there's
always the the is the young lion versus
the The Savvy vets
but one thing you're taking out of
account here when you talk about Max
holloways he's not one of those guys who
are yeah he's been around since what 18.
I've been around since he's 18 and we
saw him develop in the obscene become
you know one of the best to ever do it
in the featherweight Division if not the
best featherweight of all time you know
the fights with volkonovsky would beg to
differ but still you know Max always
been a staple of that division for how
long how many years and I think the only
non-title fight that he's lost was to
Conor McGregor back in the day
you know so every time this dude fights
if he loses it's only for a title if
it's not for a title y'all y'all in
trouble I don't care who you are so I
think the agenda here was to put over uh
Arnold Allen over Max Holloway but
you're assuming that Max always over the
hill and he's not he's like damn good
his output was ridiculous he's facing a
guy probably the toughest matchup for
Arnold Allen wasn't crazy about the
matchup to be honest for Max Holloway
but then that was me assuming that Max
always has lost his step he definitely
has it also in that fifth round which is
the only round I gave to Arnold Allen in
that fifth round
um you would probably have to say if
that thing lasts another 10-15 seconds
and I thought I was going to finish him
because at the end there uh Alan land's
a great I think he was an elbow and
they're trading literally just caution
to the win and then Max drops his ass
you know so I could when Max when he
gets you hurt he's gonna get you out of
there so they could have got a little
rough for Arnold but you know end of the
round nobody really fights like that for
an entirety of a round but shout out
Donald Allen this is the best thing that
happened for him you know could he beat
a volcanovsky right now no he's just not
there yet so I think for Arnold it's a
good learning experience for him he went
five rounds with a world-class title
Contender former world champion this is
good man and again this isn't boxing
this isn't like other leagues where you
lose one and you know it's the end of
the road no for Allen all right see you
also Mike's hallway she went to decision
to Max hallway
49-46 I agree with 4847 I don't see that
but you know these judges are morons but
49-46 was fair and the two judges got it
right so for Arnold Allen perspective
drawn board you're just not there yet he
has all the potential to be world
champion he's just not there yet that's
okay that's okay you could be homeboy
who's 18 who found the main card last
weekend and it's tough to say that not
there yet that would even be acceptable
at this point it's like you're oh dude
you gotta get jump out of the UFC get
some experience get some skill then come
back for art Island's like no we gotta
tweak a few things you're just not at
the top forward level yet you'll get
there he has all the skills to get it
done has a granite chance those Mac
hallway that's the thing Max Holloway
and Arnold Allen hits like a Mack truck
for a featherweight he lands him he
landed a left hook there flush he lands
him knee some elbows like Max Holloway's
Chin's ridiculous man Max always looked
amazing looked amazing the one that
bummed me out again this is another you
know common theme Here you had uh Billy
corn
teal cortillo who I love Billy's so much
fun to watch and cut before this barbozo
fight he was on a straight you know
Rampage
um with that's in Barboza you know you
don't know you're gonna get till that's
in Barboza that knee was just so
picture-perfect flush I don't know
anybody that wouldn't be knocked out by
that if you look how Billy's dealing
with on Twitter it's funny man it's so
funny it's so funny he just you know
he's dealing with the way you should
obviously you get the haters out there
but those people don't matter and then
with Bill he's just taking it in you
know taking stride and having fun with
it and he'll get back on the horse that
kid's a [__] monster man again you
got a young line trying to take out
etsan Barbosa he's been a staple of the
featherweight division for how long
[__] happens at the end of the world and
for do I think Billy is a better fighter
than that's in Barboza currently right
now yes
but you got caught with that knee it
happens that's what happened you know
it's in Barbosa is one of the best
strikers to ever grace the Octagon [__]
happens in this game that's why that's
why it's the toughest sport to bet on
it's by far the toughest sport to bet on
if you talk to uh legit gamblers who
make a living off gambling they hate
being on the UFC they absolutely hate it
there's too many ways to lose for Billy
he lost probably the one way he could
have lost neither the [__] face flush
yeah dude it's gonna be a short night
for you uh my boy Justin Jacoby lost
that was a great fight though uh cute
elabra Tanner bows are ridiculous I did
that I'm assuming that got fire tonight
because some of these I was able to
watch in The Green Room in Atlanta and
some had to watch this morning so father
night
oh that lgo and TJ Brown that fight was
phenomenal that's in Barboza Brandon Roy
Val Gillian Robertson all deserving
um the Brandon Roy Val again I told you
guys this last week how dare you put him
on prelims on a fight night he might
have heard you though because that's
what he said at the post oh damn almost
five personalities he's like he was so
pissed off to be at the prelims yeah
don't ever do it again it's so
disrespectful the guy of his skill level
and what he's earned in the UFC to put
him on prelims and then look what he did
to that dude ranked demolished homeboy
ridiculous the knees the elbows
ridiculous man of course uh Zach Cummins
and Ed Hermann retired yeah double
simultaneous uh retirement I think
Daniel gave him uh both 50k just being
like cool thanks for the Memories enjoy
the CT thanks for memories
um what are you gonna do that's not Dan
I'm just being silly that's cool too 50k
that's pretty yeah that's cool
um our boy clay Guida got a little bit
of heat there right I'm sure you have in
the the current events because clay
Guido we thought was going to retire and
he used to wish somebody happy birthday
Dana was not happy no no I didn't see
this I just saw that Daniel was not
happy let me see uh clay Guida's take
here you go
[Applause]
DC
I tricked you guys there ain't no way
yet I want to congratulate
there's more in the beginning but he
took off his gloves he made it seem like
he's gonna retire obviously that's not
too bad oh yeah but it was like them
forcing on him but oh he did the whole
no no that was took his gloves off did
the whole bit but yeah but Bill Algeria
the guy that was just kicking ass as
well he also pretended to retire so
there's two guys that pretended to
retire that's why Dana White was pissed
off yeah I'm with Dana I like that [__]
man
well I got a beautiful wife I got a
beautiful baby boy at home so I want to
make this official announcement
and then was that after clay
I don't know if I think bill came in
before it was before
uh yeah Bill and he got fight of the
night and that submission was ridiculous
that was such a good fight that one I
kind of vibe with because the Zach
Cummins Ed Herman double retirement like
that's the kind of that's fresh in
everybody's mind so Bill just played off
that clay Guida to do it was like dude
it just happened dude you can't do it
back to back I know it kind of ruins it
yeah that was weak dude but I love
Cleveland he can do no wrong with my
book sucks he lost though
sucks he lost
now Veronica good good fight night
though ridiculous Fight Night the UFC's
been on fire lately man with that asanya
fight card now you got this fight night
let's take a little break from the
chatting about the fisticuffs cause
guess what this episode of the shop show
is brought to you by my friend that
green Chef what's green Chef Brennan
well I'm glad you asked green Chef is a
ccof certified meal kit company green
Chef makes eating well easy with plans
to fit every lifestyle look like Dana
White forget the cleanse and eat some
green Chef whether you're keto paleo
vegan vegetarian gluten-free or just
looking to eat more bounce meals green
Chef offers a range of recipes to suit
your preferences I do the protein
because your boy has psoriasis so I
gotta be easy on the carbs all right uh
they have it all man can choose from 30
recipes weekly with an option to mix and
match meals from different uh whatever
diet you're on you can mix and match
right if you're vegan one day keto the
next we got you covered get everything
you need at Green Market our One-Stop
shop for quick breakfast is brunch kits
wholesome lunches and more you can
easily add on to your weekly order and
you're craving a little more servings of
your favorite and I can double the
portions in your weekly order with just
a single click all right green Chef is
the number one meal kit for eating well
with dinners that work for you not the
other way around all right it's super
convenient it's super easy bring more
flavor to your table and your family
this spring with green chefs wholesome
elevated recipes featuring seasonal
organic produce and unique farm fresh
ingredients like rainbow carrots bok
choy and olives that sounds nice I'm
starving right now go to greenchef.com
shop60 use the code shop 60 to get 60
off plus free shipping all right that's
greenchef.com shop 60. the number one
meal kit for eating well that's green
chef
the NBA playoffs are here and there's no
media coverage on my Denver Nuggets the
number one seed and Joker should win the
MVP but people suck and embiid will
probably do it so that's gonna
fire up my boy jokic watch the Nuggets
take this whole thing until they
probably run into Milwaukee but we'll
see either way the NBA playoffs are here
and you need to bet on the action with
my friends at draftking Sportsbook an
official sports betting part of the NBA
get in on the excitement of every game
with a touch of a button new customers
can bet five dollar pregame moneyline
bet and score 150 in bonus bets if their
team wins plus everyone can score a no
sweat same game parlay every day during
the NBA Playoffs open the draft game
Sportsbook app opt-in plays the same
game partly on any NBA game if it
doesn't hit you'll get a bonus bet back
up to 10 buckaroos the Lakers Memphis is
popping I think you've been on A.D it's
always a safe bet with Milwaukee and you
know my nuggets getting it done
Sacramento is no punk either this year
the Knicks are doing the damn thing so
there's a lot to bet on download the app
now sign up with the code shop show
schab show new customer combat five
dollar rules pregame money line bet and
score 150 dollars in bonus bets if your
team wins only at draftking Sportsbook
with the code Shop show gambling problem
call 1-800 Gambler in Massachusetts call
800-327-50 or visit gambling helpline m
a DOT org in New York call 8778 Hope and
why or text Hope and why that's 467-369
in Kansas call 100
522-4700 on behalf of Boot Hill Casino
Resort Kansas 21 or older in most
eligible states must uh but age varies
by jurisdiction eligibility restrictions
apply see draftkings.com Sportsbook for
details and state-specific responsible
gambling resources thanks for making me
read that DraftKings
this weekend's fight card not bad or boy
Curtis blades is fighting Curtis blades
I think hands down is the toughest
matchup for Jon Jones now they're not
doing any favors fighting Sergey uh
Pavlov pavlovich pavlovich they're not
doing any favors here nobody wants to
fight this Russian Frankenstein right
it's like a Mack truck here's a caveat
here though it's also Curtis Blade's
just a terrible matchup for anybody he's
in his prime he's fought all comers he's
had some losses he's learned from that
he's definitely gotten better since
those losses and then now you know
you're given pretty much a bona fide
strike like this guy hasn't fought a lot
of Grapplers he beat tied to a Vasa
Derrick Lewis Maurice Green you know and
then they have a common opponent
Alistair Overeem see what Curtis plays
the Dallas Wolverine you see a Molly [__]
Alistair over him like literally Big
Brother bully MTV Bully Beatdown so
um as much as I you know they're not
doing Curtis blades any favors they had
nothing else do with them right now with
John and Steve a fighting that's
supposed to happen in math Square Garden
according to rumors
um but I do think on paper stylistically
Curtis blades is by far the toughest
matchup for Jon Jones gives them most
frits too anchors blades wants that
fight my God does he want that fight
George blades too if you listen to my
food truck I'm sure we'll put a clip up
this week lean up to the fight but curse
Blade's only goal is to set the all-time
takedown record you know in the UFC and
he's getting close he's going to get up
a bunch of takedown Saturday
so I got who's the favorite in that Jim
I assume Curtis is a slight favorite see
going downtown
yep minus 165 that's fair
I'll take that all day
your boy song sung yo dong Underdog
against Ricky Simone I love Ricky though
I'm thinking Ricky Brad Tavares I think
he's a dog I'll take Brad we've got
Bobby green Jared Gordon how about Jared
Gordon didn't really take any hits you
know the majority of the fan base thinks
he beat Patty pimlin to even Bobby green
that is not an easy fight for him but
you're going to talented dude
not mad at this fight night at all God
talk about a throwback Ronnie yeah Jesus
Christ
yeah uh who's been fighting not Camaro
the giant Muhammad Usman
he's back at it
fun card though that the the main card
is definitely fun Sergey Curtis blades
uh Sonia dong Ricky Simone Brett Tavares
Bruno Silva Bobby green Jared Gordon
I'll take it not mad at it this thing's
getting overshadowed though because you
have uh biggest fight of the year in
boxing by far even though it's early
it's a little early we're not even mid
right of 2023 not not yet
um Javonte Davis Ryan Garcia is
happening folks and uh it's happening
this Saturday on Showtime pay-per-view
9 pm Eastern which means they won't
fight to probably midnight Eastern
whatever
um it's in Las Vegas Nevada they finally
got it done I can't excite him for this
fight because boxing usually to get
these guys and they're both you know I
would say
um Ryan Garcia's in his prime yet I'd
say Javonte is right now but still
Ryan's he's getting there and it's rare
usually we get these fights when they're
both you know their nuts are hanging off
the ground they have calluses on their
Knuckles so
um shout out to box and for getting this
done shout out to no one's giving Ryan
Garcia credit for this dude the [__] he
had to give up in that contract to make
this fight happen this is this is what
makes me hesitant for all those doubters
out there doubting Ryan Garcia him
giving up as much he did with the rehyd
duration clause and a bunch of other
stuff that's not out there that I talked
to Ryan about he had to give up a
shitload just to get this deal done
my argument there is for Javonte Davis
if you're so confident why are you
putting all these stipulations in that
contract in order to fight Ryan
and then for me it's like well if Ryan
agrees this which nobody ever would
agree to all the stuff he agreed to to
get this fight done there has to be
something we don't know that he's seeing
in Javonte Davis game the guy's
undefeated I get it there has to be
something there in order to give up that
much ground but yeah let's just make I
don't care whatever it takes yeah put it
in yep I'm down to do that rehydration
Clause not a big deal dude let's do this
that too you got it like
jeront Dave's team made it so damn
impossible that most Fighters would turn
it down Ryan went I'm good with it to
meet geese this is the confidence of him
and his team it's Ryan Garcia dude there
has to be something we don't know going
down you know they see some sort of
[__] in the armor there
but he's gonna he's so confident skill
set to get this fight done because on
paper you know Tank's a big favorite a
very what is each and uh is he a minus
300 minus 400 at this point is it down
to two
Canelo minus 1400 there it is can't wait
for that one says minus 270. Ryan's plus
205. yeah you know that goes to Ryan's
popularity you know the line moved
pretty because he was I think uh started
off as almost a minus 400 you know which
is a huge favor especially with two
undefeateds now they do have a common
opponent Ryan fought the guy a little
later in his career Ryan knocked around
the first round tank got done the eighth
round there's just different styles
um
there is a way for Ryan Garcia to win
this fight I think part of the Prime too
what some of the knock on Ryan Garcia is
you guys see him as this tick tocker and
YouTuber you don't remember how young he
is so yeah the kid looks like a freaking
dime piece and you know looks like a
young Golden Boy he has a lot of semi
similarities to Oscar De La Hoya The
Golden Boy which obviously his uh
his reputation is a little tainted but
people forget how [__] good Oscar De
La Hoya was and Ryan Garcia is on that
same path minus the stockings and all
that [__] that came out but in the
cocaine but for Ryan Garcia
again you guys get it twisted yeah he's
this YouTuber he makes all this money
off Tick Tock a lot of stuff that's just
being a smart businessman and he's
keeping up with the times that's why
he's so popular because he's really the
face of box when it comes that younger
generation so I don't knock them for
that but people confuse that in that
silly [__] with his skill level so in
boxing series seven you know 15 time
World Champ not easy man not easy you
know from his Golden Gloves amateur you
know this kid is a [__] monster he's
a monster man so you know his Gatorade
Campaign which is insane
um first American boxer ever to appear
on Gatorade yeah yeah that's all the
Social Media stuff like that so they
have a common opponent
Ryan did get him out of there first that
doesn't say too much he did fight him
later Ryan has out of the two of them
they're both undefeated and they're both
knockout artists I would say Javonte
Davis is is more powerful is a scary uh
scarier fighter to to face
um I'd say Ryan's the quicker fighter
Ryan's gonna have to be on his bike he's
gonna have to for 12 rounds we're facing
again Javonte Davis who has that kind of
power that you're born with there's no
gym there's no coach there's no bag you
can work on to get that power that is a
god-given gift Javonte Davis has a
god-given gift Ryan Garcia has a
god-giving gift and his speed but his
power isn't thing we any is it anything
we haven't seen But when you combine the
power with the quickness is when Ryan
knocks people out so I think you know
for this fight there's a reason why
Javon Davis is the favorite
um out of the two again Ryan's the only
one that's been knocked down he got
knocked down that Luke Campbell fight
right which he went on to win but it's
the only time he's been knocked down
so we see that Ryan has a good chin we
don't know [__] about Javonte Davis's
chin and it will get tested in this
fight
Ryan's too quick he's gonna land stuff
and in order for tank to win the fight
he has to walk through some [__] and
that [__] is the quickness and speed of
Ryan Garcia which could leave him open
so we're gonna find out is tank I think
the pound for pound best right now
outside Canelo but right now as you
pound for pound best right now
what's he like when he gets hit if he
does get knocked down how does he
recover this fight ain't going to
decision if he goes decision I think
Ryan wins I think Ryan wins and he can't
give up rounds early either he got to
win those early rounds you got to put
that money in the bank early on stay on
your bike out maneuver him use your
quickness and wait for Javonte who I
think probably has a higher box of IQ
and has you know a little more uh a
little more experience too when it comes
to the big fights and the big pressure
fights and has faced tougher adversity
so I do think there's a way for Ryan to
win not gonna be easy we need tank to
step out of pocket and make some
mistakes and you need Ryan to land with
his speed and quickness and even so if
that does land the question is
is that enough to get tank out of there
we haven't really seen tank get hit I
haven't seen him get hit definitely
haven't seen him get knocked down like
Ryan we've seen Ryan get knocked down
get back up and finish the dude off in
Campbell so you know there's a lot of uh
questions to be answered here again I I
go back to why in the world with Ryan's
team Ryan Garcia's team give up so much
just get this fight done
and everybody else scared of tank Davis
Ryan Garcia's team sought out this fight
not only did they see the fight make it
happen but gave up many things that
other Fighters would refuse to it would
never happen look what's going on with
uh you look what's going on with Fury in
that fight
no there's too much [__] in that
contract usick wants 70 30 split in the
rematch so he's running into the fire
when most Fighters run around it or try
to navigate around it do the whole PR
thing you got to give Ryan credit he's
running towards this which is insane
tank is no punk so we're gonna find out
rooting for tank I'm sorry I'm rooting
for Ryan I'm running for Ryan all the
way I'm a homer I'm biased friends my
boy I think he can get it done if he's
he has it has to be the best performance
of his life the very best I think they
do run this fight back two or three
times but there's so many guys out there
too you know there's a lot of other guys
out there that we want to see Ryan
Garcia fight and I think Ryan has that
personality like the old school guys
where they make fights happen that the
fans want to see that's why I like Ryan
so I think for boxing be better for Ryan
one because he's not he's you know he's
gonna fight those other guys
he's down to make those fights happen
whatever it takes just so the fans see
who's the best who's the perennial no
question Undisputed world champion
because right now we don't know because
they have these belts but they haven't
fought the top guys they just haven't
Ryan's down to make that happen when
boxing over time they used to do this
but now recently with all the belts they
kind of run from each other there's
reason you don't get the although they
did announce it but the Crawford Spence
fight think how long that took Floyd
maywether mini Pacquiao usick Fury you
know
it's just they run from each other it's
the problem with boxing Ryan Garcia's
Cut From a Different Cloth he's been
doing this since he was seven my
favorite part is when you listen to
these boxes now let's go you know
jovantes are doing a lot longer he
started when he was five it's like
do you think those two years really make
it that big of a difference when you're
five to seven
you know
so I'm excited for it though man I'm
super excited for it real quick on the
the Joshua no not Joshua Theory and
usick I remember like it was supposed to
be 70 30 and then the rematch clause I
think usaga wanted 50 if usiguan he just
wants 50 50 which is great but they
turned it down or something like that no
it was so the first it's backwards the
first site was 50 50 second five was 70
30.
yeah fury like get the [__] out of here
that sounds insane all the way around
yeah no
you might be right Jim but that's what I
thought there was the problem because
I'm pretty sure yeah it was the hold up
was in the rematch clause
the shop show is brought to you by my
my longest Partnership of all time talk
about on it the best supplements on
planet Earth they have the best
nootropic on the planet and they can get
it to you however you want you want the
instant One-Shot Alpha instant we got
you you want a little put in eight
ounces of water to get the instant Alpha
Brain hit you gotcha you want just a red
glass for brain like everybody else is
taking they've sold over a million
bottles go ahead and do that great no
return necessary they'll refund your
money if you don't love it but you're
gonna love it but I use the Black Label
the Alpha Brain Black Label heavy on the
brain I love it helps support cognitive
functions including memory mental speed
and focus I need all the help I can get
AIDS and mental processing it's caffeine
free helps get you to the Flow State all
right it helps you remember names focus
on complex tasks think more clearly
under stress you react a little more
quickly like Ryan Garcia perhaps on it
also offers the best fitness gear in the
world kettlebell steel Club Macy's
sandbags yoga mats and you need protein
powders you need Warrior bars you need
mc2l you need some shroom contact
whatever you need audit has the best
supplements they also have on-demand
workout stream and fitness no need to go
to gym you can stream it from your phone
your tablet whatever you want on-demand
streaming Fitness with on it all right
so if you're thick ass you get in better
shape let audit help you get you there
audit.com receive temperature off
everything I mentioned about Alpha Brain
all sorts of alpha brains the instant
the the quick shot the Alpha Brain Black
you save temperature for all of it
audit.com
you're welcome
last week then we're back to the chatter
listen you guys know me I only recommend
products that I actually use on a daily
basis this next product is one I use on
every single episode whether you're
watching the shop show golden hour
fighting the kid I'm doing stand up I'm
doing somebody else's podcast just in
life I'm using the best Kratom on the
planet and it's from Happy Hippo this
stuff helps you tackle your busy
schedule helps you get stuff done it
gives you just that nice feeling balance
a good mood feeling and it helps get you
focused on what ever you're trying to
accomplish in your life and you can get
Kratom and I know Kratom can be a little
dicey but you can trust happy hippo
that's why I ride with happy hippo all
right they have the instant shots I have
here this is the sour apple I like sour
apple like the Butterscotch the instant
Kratom shot straight to the Dome they
have pills gummy powder however you want
to get your Kratom get it from Happy
Hippo trust your boy here go to
happyhippo.com thick23 is the promo code
you save 20 off for Life share it with
your friends use it many times you want
for the best Kratom on the freaking
planet that's Happy hippo.com promo code
thick with three C's 23 20 off
happyhippo.com let's get back to the
program
what do you got for me Jen alrighty
a lot of rain today a lot of coffee
uh let's go to oh so what'd you think
about Max Holloway's call out of of all
people Korean zombie
I just it it feels like
I may be a phenomenal fight you know and
I see where what Max is doing you know
it makes sense and he'd definitely be a
favorite in that fight
um
so Korean zombie that is the only guy in
my time with the older guys that I
didn't get to fight I get that I would
love that fight there's a fight in my
agent's country
uh Australia coming up Australia
supposed to be happening sometime we
don't know when and if Korean zombie
wants to get it he can get it he can get
it
I get it you know they came up kind of
similar time
um
I would like to fight Max to be a huge
favorite I'm just weird to call out an
older guy like that it's a gimme fight
for Max 2 and maybe he looks at
divisions like when I just keep hanging
around beating up guys less famous than
me that are tougher fights you want the
biggest name the easiest fight possible
I'm not saying Max looking for easy
fights but this would be one of them
that's demolish it screams on me I'm
anxious as much as I obviously
I hear a homer but if I did like you
know of course I think Max will win but
dude their Styles would make such an
amazing fight dude yeah fight at night
that could be on a pay-per-view all day
or a main event on Fight Night oh damn
like korean's I'm doing the damn thing
he posted uh this video afterwards in
English by the way
let's go brother
that's it
if we want to fight me anytime anywhere
let's go brother that's a great [__]
fight for both Korean zombie too there's
not many left in the chamber right yeah
so that makes sense it makes sense for
both guys because go to the division go
that featherweight division
so yeah vulcanovski who I don't see
anybody beating him it's just not
happening now so then you got Max at two
so the number one guy yair is fighting
you're going to take it they're very
fought he beat Arnold Allen at four you
got Josh Emmett who has a tough fight
coming up
Chan sung Jung there he is Calvin Kateri
fought what else you gonna do like if
you're a Mac you want to take control of
your career what else you're gonna do
makes sense you still ranked six
card big name perfect style fight
I like it Max eats his ass up
scared for zombie but the way you fight
the way you eat [__] prime rib on
that Korean Grill that's what Max is
doing Korean zombie although Korean
zombies no punk right no I mean he
always comes out yeah yeah you never
know what's gonna happen but I'm with
Mac like you look at the the lineups
like all right yeah yeah you're there
you got volkanovsky which
and then broken I see like damn Max quit
beating up contenders dude I have no one
to fight to keep beating up all these
young lines like I need contenders
because if because if voknowski let's
say he destroys yair which I think he
does let's say he destroys yair
all right Arnold's last so Arnold's
gonna have to win at least one two more
before you title shot Brian Ortega he's
flat Max always three times he then say
bti air
yeah Josh emit sitting there Josh is a
very tough fight coming up can't do
Korean zombie
can't do Calvin kater
you know it's like
the poor is probably the Dark Horse
there
wins too you know
that division is tough
so she have a dominant Champion
volkonowsky super dominant
interesting
all right the biggest news over the week
was the announcement of Jake Paul vs I
love this boxing I love this and this is
uh
this is what we're talking about so you
know last week I saw out Francis and
Ghana where it's it's a mistake if he
goes anywhere else any other
organization just for MMA and doesn't
land that big key boxing fight him
leaving was a mistake now he might make
a few more million dollars or a few more
hundred thousand dollars I don't know
the difference but if you don't get the
[__] you fight boxing fight with Deontay
Wilder whoever it is Wilder Fury we
haven't heard anything on that then you
made a huge mistake for Nate to leave
and then shortly after he leaves the net
and you know he couldn't announce
anything because of the UFC uh legal
[__] but as soon as he could there's
negotiations going on so Nate retires
Nate stays active on social media so
he's still in our face he's talking [__]
about Fighters still he's still his
name's still at the top of our minds he
retires and then shortly after boom Jake
Paul Nate Diaz yeah I made the right
choice hell yeah dude get yours get
yours
it's an interesting fight this is the
thing as soon as I saw us on Twitter
people think I'm talking [__] no I'm not
oh I think it's Jake's toughest fight I
think he's tough for him than uh Tommy
Fury but
The Narrative on Jake is all his fights
are fake and they're they're they're set
up and we know who's he knows who's
going to win there's you know he's not a
real boxer okay cool well do you think
in any [__] facet there's enough
money in this world that they could pay
Nate Diaz to take a fall against Jake
Paul
if you're a fan of Nate Diaz or Nick
Diaz you know the Diaz brothers would
not compromise they do not play that
[__] they're set financially specially
Nate super set off the counter stuff but
do you think in any [__] facet that
Nate would be willing to take any sum of
money
500 mil not a chance I don't think Jake
could pay him that much but say he could
you think Nate would would take that hit
on his legacy to lose to a YouTuber
not a chance so at what point do you
guys have to go all right that narrative
that lie isn't working anymore because
now he's because if it was working he
would be Tommy Fury right if it was
working he wouldn't find any ideas so
that doesn't work so like I always say
when the hate doesn't work they start
telling lies but that lie definitely
doesn't work here
if you know anything about the Diaz
brothers there's not a any amount of
money that you could offer them where
they're going to take a fall and a
[__] fight against a YouTuber you're
out of your mind this is the the real
[__] deal man you guys got to quit
with that stuff it's a huge test for
Jake because the volume of Nate the chin
of Nate it you know and after I was one
of the first guys after he fought
Anderson like now I can at first before
he finally I understand I was like I
don't like the the Nate Diaz fight for
Jake's terrible idea he fought Anderson
looked good showed some boxing IQ you
know was in there he he got hurt he came
back he dropped the Henderson Silva I
was like oh [__] and they might be
Nate's gonna be some trouble you can't
watch that if I think that Nate's not in
trouble they see the time you feel you
fight like okay this is a good fight
are there odds out yet
should be yeah oh yeah I assume Jake's a
slight favorite
and it's eight rounds
I think it is eight rounds and it's at
185. 12 rounds would be better for now
minus 275 for Paul and then Nate's at
plus two one interesting
interesting
not a bad idea put some money on Nate
is this a FICA painting what do you
think what is it
I think August so it's way ahead August
5th I think it is that's a fight
campaign yeah no ideas Jake [__] you
that's a [__] man
and they usually fight on Sundays but I
don't know if August 5th is a Sunday or
not
um it is August
football season starts in
yeah I think first games in September
you're dealing with preseason they don't
want to they don't want to take on uh
any uh Saturday
but Saturday yeah when they're fighting
yep perfect August 5th perfect
alrighty the other big news over the
weekend
I mean you called this already too oh no
over the weekend last week but you
called it so Alex player he made an
announcement on his YouTube channel that
he's moving up to 205 not because he
can't make 185 anymore so he says yeah
he said he already did enough you know
he got the championship so he wants to
do something else and he's a great
phenomenal fighter and uh like
heavyweight good [__] lucky light
heavyweight good luck those guys up
there good luck yeah
kick rocks nerd he's the only guy
anybody else good [__] locked all of
them
my bed
you're not you're the same for you but
the rest of them Yuri Hill yawn rakik
Anthony Smith krylov Johnny Walker call
him out Vulcan
good luck good [__] luck against that
guy at light heavy weight not cut all
that weight good luck man he's even
dominate it's brilliant brilliant I
can't wait to see it oh yeah
I'm not mad if they gave him Johnny
Walker for the first fight just gives a
little taste whether he's like at 205. I
think it'd be smart for him too like
let's see how it feels into it because
Johnny Walker is not like a world beater
yet you know he's seven but and he's
getting his [__] back together working
um at SPG yeah he's kind of getting his
[__] together but still he's not the
same as like a yawn or magamed or rakik
or yeri or even Jamal Hill he's you know
he's not on that level yet I like it so
bill because you put him at the title
shots all right Jesus Christ
all right you mentioned this earlier how
Dana White
um or not they know what but Jon Jones
versus cpmoches is going to be moved to
MSG and later in the fall the original
date was July but something happened and
there was like rumors that Dana was
trying to he said he said Jon Jones just
disappeared yeah
so Stipe posted oh no yes Stephen posted
this and this is from Pat McAfee show I
think
yeah
give me one sec
and who he's gone again John Jones goes
back underground and uh you know and and
let me know when the steepe fight's done
and it's it's he is a he is a
fascinating talented artist to deal with
so you have not heard from him since wow
I haven't heard a word on him
please Deuces [__] I'm gonna enjoy this
win
weird because last month he said I was
the one running hilarious they just need
to [__] fight don't they yeah and
then Jones I lay low for a few weeks and
you convince yourself that I'm afraid of
you ha whatever you need to tell
yourself old-timer
and then this was
how cool how cool would it be to spend
my retirement fight dominating the
greatest heavyweight of all time in my
home state at Madison Square Garden
uh it doesn't mean it's getting done
does it and then a fan a fan wrote this
and he wrote back chill I'm not ready
for retirement okay my bad I'll keep
fighting yeah
they just need a [__] fight yeah I'm
down with waiting till fall July would
have been awesome but whatever July is
the move let's be real just get also
John how much you're out for three years
you're the easiest fighting career you
beat the guy in a minute you didn't get
touched what what are we recovering from
get to [__] working or or what I
think is going on is he's just over it
and he's like yeah I'll get when I can
like I'm good man
like I only have two flights left
there's no reason to knock out all we're
in a rush in a rush okay yeah give me
I'll fight once or twice a year off you
know I fought gone early now fight Stipe
when I can fight Stipe that'd be his
last fight this year the next year maybe
it's the curse blades or if they can
negotiate with Francis and that's it man
I think this just shows you that John
maybe has two or three left Max three I
think probably two
if not one because he could be sleeping
if he's acting like this after a minute
he can get touched
foreign
I mean it could be like I don't know
contract stuff as much as more money no
Deal's over Deal's over they've already
made the deal
all right so this is a rumor that's been
floating around for this weekend at
least a lot of people got us yeah a lot
of people were saying a lot of people
text me and I told you I'm like did you
hear about shots and Tony Ferguson we're
like you were like no I'm like what
that's [__] up dude
no but it kind of did when if you say
170 in the uh well again it's a young
lion and they're getting the old line
you know either one put out the pasture
yeah that's what's going on there so
here's the thing yeah terrible room
terrible matchup but it was like yeah
don't surprise me if they do it it's
[__] up I guarantee you Tony would
take the fight
don't even give a flying [__] yeah but
people referenced or they tagged with
like the source was Brett okamoto and of
course everyone exactly well yeah Brett
is retaining his right hand man it used
to be Ariel now it's brat so it's like
when when I saw the tag it but that's I
think I you know because I don't see a
lot of social media so I saw when my
friends were texting me I'm like who'd
you hear from like Brad I'll come out
I'm like oh that that's it that's legit
hmm Jenna was few tiger thanks deep he's
like no absolutely no why would they do
that I don't know Brad akamoto said it
Madness that's the internet
um and this is also rumor but um so
Hamza and this is by what channel I
think chill announces a potential
matchup between uh yeah I think someone
in the UFC by someone I mean probably
Dana feeds it to jail and then Chael
runs with it and then people get excited
and stuff yep yep very smart very
calculated
all right this is a bummer I get the
news of like shove shove cry and Tony
Ferguson like yeah there you go I'm like
thanks man
oh this one so Charles
uh I guess Charles has an undisclosed
injury I know dang it but at least for
now it seems like they're rebooking it
first that means injury can't be too bad
yeah so just a month difference
but yeah
it sucks for video
yeah
um here's a bout announcement Brandon
Moreno versus
Pantoja two uh Brandon lost their first
fight back in the day yeah back in the
day but then they're fighting at UFC
290.
alrighty Davis Davidson figurative
versus Manila cup Davidson I wanted
figarito versus uh my boy
um who we just had on food truck
oh Cory wanted that too
so Dave's not supposed to go down oh
sorry it's supposed to go up but he's
gonna stay a fly away right now for this
oh yeah oh definitely okay so he's doing
one more at flyweight and then gone okay
so yeah it wouldn't happen anyways but
yeah
then let's go to
oh this was just kind of a silly one as
soon as uh Jamal Hill found out that
Alex prayer is going to go up to light
heavyweight
he posted this video here he's funny on
the grandma Yeah
[Music]
so basically means welcome
can't wait to see you
it's like come knock on my door
something like that and then
hold on
and then prayer responded I'm coming to
kick your door in
yeah it's a good fight for Alex but I
just don't think Alton come off it's
tough because I don't think Alex can
come off a loss to Izzy and then jump in
and fight for a title I think the the
Johnny Walker makes the most sense then
you win that one then it's title shot so
just one just one yeah like uh like uh
Hamza at middleweight we need one Paul
Apollo uh Costa makes all the sense beat
him who's a been a perennial top five
guy you mop the floor with him all right
title shot
yeah and the back and forth between both
of them will be great yeah
awful fight for Paul I know awful fun
yep I agree awful fight yes he's like
yeah no doubt man we're gonna give you
this huge contract here's homplot though
I know you know it's like oof
okay so this was interesting
made of posted his goat greatest of all
time 15 lists hey here's my thing do you
think
khabib really made this list
you think you could be sitting down and
you know how long this would take first
of all you don't even care to do 45
minutes to go through all this [__] yeah
so this is khabib khabib slash managers
top uh 15 goats number one is a tie
between Fredo and Jones that's fair
number two GSP number three Anderson
Silva number four DJ number five DC six
Henry sahuto Jose Aldo come out Usman
asani at nine BJ Penn hoyce Gracie
Couture Kane tied hendo Shogun tied Crow
cop 14 Dominic Cruz Frankie Edgar 15.
okay
do you think the misspellings of some of
the names is to make it more authentic
looking yeah yeah so so we buy into it
more but you're not you're not fooling
anybody
nah
and then DC put your number one champ of
all on of all on the list you are only
on the only undefeated guy 29-0
undefeated yeah like his resume though
DC yeah so Connor responded to that
obviously
and then this is what Conor said
oh
in the end it's who's laugh don't forget
God bless people who didn't retire after
they you know yeah who's still in the
game
[Music]
Jones and then the rest is whatever
that's hilarious I don't get how you
don't have vocalowski on that list I
guess if we beat um
Market Jeff
that list is funny though definitely not
him writing though right you guys know
this you're right no [__] what the
hell
all right
okay let's go to this is cool Robbie
Lawler versus Rory McDonald from UFC 189
they're gonna join the the fight winner
of the USC Hall of Fame insane just
their personality everything was awesome
it's dude yeah
that fight changed uh the trajectory of
Rory mcdon's career yeah
sometimes leave a little piece yourself
in there
so it turns out when Ezra was talking
about someone didn't want to say the
name it was that guy drinking stupid
yeah suplexes because they're both from
Africa he said I'll drag his car just
all through stuff yeah
so it because it started becoming this
weird thing like I think Israel out of
Sanya and Kamar Osman took it as in
because there's white Africans you know
South Africa and there's also black ones
and they're maybe thought like something
was a race thing yeah somehow it kind of
would have to be a race thing that's why
yeah I doubt it is but that's how you
know they took it what they say I'm not
interested seeing this fight at all
I know his coach was like I know this
coach is like yeah he got his nose fixed
and you breathe better now oh that was
another thing too he said that he gonna
it's pretty like eight percent uh really
eight percent oxygen three each nostril
what's that gave you that and then a
doctor refuted it immediately you'd be
dead if that was the case yeah yeah
doctor's like yeah I don't think so yeah
so he won't say my name that's smart you
better not I don't I don't need your air
time at all I have my whole continent of
Africa behind me oh you think you're
more popular in Africa than Israel okay
uh go enjoy your verse protective
victory at home in New Zealand you'll
see Africa is far from being done at
least another year I'll meet you in
neutral ground this year if you still
feel so strongly after face me I take
your belt home I'll give you another
chance to come and try and face me on my
home Capital my home Green Bow Alabama
my home soil of I Africa we are Africa
we fear nothing certainly nobody hashtag
still knocks hashtag we are Africa
hashtag proudly African hashtag proudly
Southern African hashtag green and gold
that's like world champions hashtag We
Are One hashtag Africa for the win
hashtag UFC gold coming home to Africa
hashtag we fear no man have hashtag
Africa again he's pushing the African
thing because he's his point was like
because he's live he's literally lives
there trains there and Israel's not you
know New Zealand so he's like if I get
the belt then I'll be the actual person
yeah which is like why pushing it that
hard though that's I don't know yeah I
think maybe because here's the thing he
has a good chance to get this uh title
shot more power to him I like what he's
doing I respond I do exactly what he's
doing the eight percent thing really was
just ridiculous I mean so stupid even he
said like a coach said his own things
coach like yeah you don't think he can
beat Izzy because his cardio it's like
yes cardio is not great you can only
breathe you can't even breathe how about
that can't breathe and we got him
surgery and he can breathe now so he's
gonna do better okay
it's okay Coach you're in charge of his
cardio right let's work on that
um but did you look at the content
there's not much left for for his yet
middleweight so this could definitely
happen
um
what do you think of this fight card I
guess a lot of people I think people
some people in the media might as well
be saying this but the UFC 288
pay-per-view main card they're saying is
like a really weak card
and this is like the foreign
card now they all can't be gangbusters
like they used to be back in the day
because UFC has spawned so many fights
Al Joe Henry occupied alone eighty
dollars they're worth it uh just got on
drugs young okay on stuff dude over who
I absolutely love Matt Corolla that's
cool that's a good fight
just dropped a groundbreaking uh Flat
Earth really yep feature my boy Eddie
Bravo so that's gonna go over great with
the fans uh Chrome Grace who I love to
see I'm not mad at it but again it's not
I get how fans can be upset like I would
honestly say from outside Al Joe and
Henry being this you know super fight
the rest of those fights could
definitely be on a fight night
like if that was a fight and he'd be
like you'll see good card even though
you wouldn't pay eighty dollars for it
but you're paying eight dollars for Al
Joe and Henry sahudo that's no knock
anybody else is just what you know
so instead outside of aljo's Steamroller
this is horrifying dude horrified
he's gonna admit as [__]
yeah I I I'm listen I I watch it all I
pay for whatever I'm not there's some
great matchups
Steamroller is fantastic Drew Dover
that's a great fight that could that
should be a main event on a fight night
yeah that's what I agree with
all right so this is pretty cool this is
from once again Sandhu MMA uh this is a
post from Israel on February 26th
2022.
what's it say April 8th the greatest
comeback in like middleweight history or
something like or something like that
when he's gonna April 8th
the greatest comeback in sports history
is written by me he wrote down his
mirror
yeah last year
this guy goes does he post this have he
lost damned you must be great at
barbecues Jesus Christ he posted already
yeah in February so yeah do we see this
to be lost no dude why did you post that
be terrible
uh here's some quick ones that he
inspired you cook I know that is super
inspiring yeah too his win was just
lighting up the haters just like have
you seen him on Twitter just a
screenshot and slightly because before
the fight they're saying all the [__]
has a screenshot I'm like really dumbass
just lighting him up
people are I'm a fan base some are
[__] amazing but some of them are
actual dicks to where they will message
them like hey you you [__] suck what
the [__] I lost my bet you piece of [__]
yeah what the hell is that you'll be
seventy dollars I can't feed my lizard
this week it's like okay dude maybe you
should have bought lizards if you're
banking on [__] Pierre beating Izzy
it's just [__] it's lame yeah it's the
most toxic fan base it is what it is so
this is Rob DeVos really doing the jump
from the orange no this is a challenge
this guy kill kill fee like when they do
selfies on Ledges and on like they call
them kill fees that's what I heard that
is dark why is he doing this
so he got a lot of [__] for this
yeah it's just silly
at least he's small
so he's on top of a building somewhere
on the edge this dude just doing for
whatever for the ground
oh
everybody laughing like that though
I don't like any of them terrible no I
just with the pros cons pros you get 14
000 likes
cons you've Fallen die
uh so this was on I followed Dana White
on Instagram he does he did this post
about the you know the the doctor or
whatever to help him with his life it
was like I did your blood work you're
gonna die November 1st 2029. it seems
like holy [__] take all my money say
more
so the doctor recommended I'm not sure
he's even a doctor like here's my thing
with all this I know where you go if
Dana like Dana 53 is
tread yeah you'll see you're here might
want to listen to him even though you
know the guy off clearly the doctor's a
[__] magician or Healthcare I'm not
sure if he's a doctor I don't know what
the [__] whatever he's doing it's
[__] working Dana looks great he does
so it's like all right this guy they put
gotta 600 to burn then Dana White has a
deal for you what is it this is like a
body cleanse saying that that same guy
doctor or health guy expert um
recommended for Dana and Dana loves it
so you made this post he's not he said
he's not making a you know he has no
skin in the game or anything but he's
wanted to promote this post but then you
see his body here in this post
oh damn post his body yeah
in 10 months I'll be with him a year in
June and my blood work is perfect
physically and mentally and in every way
that you can be good I'm good and I
always wanted to do a cleanse and before
I was with Gary I had all these problems
I was on medication I'm on no doctor's
meds anymore you know I had uh insomnia
I had sleep apnea I had I snored that
all this stuff is gone I could go out
for 15 minutes about all the things that
he's
um fixed that was wrong with me but I've
always wanted to do a cleanse and I
never you know you hear all this stuff
out there you know cayenne pepper lemons
and all this [__] Gary uh told me
about this cleanse that he found he says
it's the best in the world the company
is called uh Zen Cleanse right and this
one is the colon this one does the colon
and then this one here which is called
the rainbow does the uh the colon the
liver and the uh gallbladder I could
probably use them and if it were it was
an incredible experience for me I I
fasted from a Friday to a Monday and
only did the cleanse and you know I'm
going to show you some pictures here of
me during the cleanse this thing was so
good I'm not being paid for this I got
no skin in this game I bought 10 of each
now I bought 10 of each of these to give
to friends so basically said he bought
10 of them to give family and friends
and then you saw his body there yeah
otherwise he's like I do it 10 weeks in
a row I don't eat yeah he looks great
it's hard to argue yeah at his age
that's cool if it's a cleanse but 500. I
went to the website it I saw like
bundles for a thousand something and
then some were like 264 if you just
wanted the single thing that's four days
summer a month long summer yeah it just
depends uh cleansing for but I mean do
you believe in cleanses yeah I remember
reading about some some people say like
that's not real and some people say it
is I don't know
he does look good man yeah there's no
doubt about that
53 too
there you go
um that seems to hold on one sec those
were function thanks dude
there was one more
oh this is Darren till calling out all
these different boxers
right here
Carl fresh is a long nose [__] Rocky
feeling is a big lanky [__] house Toby
fear is a fat [__] juice head and Joe
Joyce is a fat miserable [__] all can
get it let's go trolls [__]
shithouses yeah till being till and then
Rocky Fielding did call him out though
let's who is uh is one then July August
uh Echo Arena however many rounds of
minutes you want let's go and he is 30
and 30. yeah that guy's gonna be a
problem
yeah that guy's gonna be a [__]
nightmare for uh for dinner that'd be a
bad idea for till I don't like till it's
gone out Rocky field and that'd be a
terrible idea
is that it that is it my kids enjoy Ryan
Garcia tank Davis this Saturday yeah
pavlovich and uh our boy Curtis blades
going down as well so enjoy the fights
all right that's it man love you guys
thanks for watching thanks for listening
love you be safe be nice to each other
till next time I'm out